Transcriber: Helin Erden
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
Merhaba, ben Sümeyye Boyacı.
Cumhuriyet tarihimizin ilk
kadın Avrupa şampiyonuyum.
Hem engellilerde hem de
normallerde, yüzmede.
Buraya şampiyon, ressam, ebruzen,
öğrenci, minik bir aşçı, amatör bir terzi,
en önemlisi de hiçbir başarının tesadüf
olmadığını anlatacak biri olarak geldim.
Sizlere, bu 15 yıl içerisinde başarıya
giden yolun hiç de kolay olmadığından,
ne kadar çileli ve yorucu
olduğundan bahsedeceğim
fakat ben engelleri nasıl aştıysam
herkes her türlü zorluğun
üstesinden gelebilir.
Benim hikâyem, 5 Şubat 2003'te
dünyaya gelmemle başladı.
Hepinizden farklı olarak,
doğuştan iki kolum yoktu
ama kimsenin görmediği kanatlarım vardı,
yaşama sevincim, tutkum ve annem.
(Alkış)
Ailem, ben daha doğmadan benim
böyle olacağımı bildiklerinden
beni hayata kazandırmanın
yollarını araştırmışlardı.
Hatta ben doğmadan, benim gibi
bir sürü kişiyi ziyaret etmişlerdi.
Onlar sayesinde kollarımın
yokluğunu değil,
ayaklarımın varlığını hissetmiştim.
Hatta ben daha altı aylıkken
annemin ayaklarımı çiçeklere değdirmesiyle
dokunma, kavrama hissimi kazanmıştım.
O yüzden de hayatım boyunca
sadece bir çift çorap eskittim
çünkü her şeyi ayaklarımla yaptığım için
çoraplarımı çıkardığım yerde unutuyorum.
Derken, süreç normal bir çocuğun
gelişimi gibi devam etti.
İki buçuk yaşında döke saça yemek yemeler
ve üç buçuk yaşındayken
- evde kimse yok, annem
mutfakta, ben salonda -
bir gül resmi çizmiştim,
ki annem hâlâ "Evde başkası olsaydı
onu senin yaptığına inanmazdım," diyor.
Bu şekilde aileme resme olan
yeteneğimi gösteriyorum,
onlar da bana ellerinden gelen her türlü
maddi, manevi desteği sağlıyorlar.
Bir gün, dört beş yaşlarındayken
sokakta giderken, bebek arabasında
-- bu arada bir parantez açıyorum:
bebek arabası kullanıyorum
çünkü bir bacağım diğerinden kısa
ve küçükken yürümekte zorluk
çekip sürekli düşüyordum.
Hatta dört kere yardığım çenem de
o günlerin izini hala taşıyor.
Olaya geri dönüyorum.
Apartmanların birinden
bir kadın bağırıyor:
"Aaa, yok mu onun kolları?
Nerede onun kolları?"
Yol boyunca çok üzülüyor, bozuluyorum
ve hiç konuşmuyorum.
Normalde konuşmaya bayılan,
susmak bilmeyen bir çocuktum
ama tek kelime etmiyorum.
Eve gittiğimizde hemen rengarenk
boya kalemlerimin başına oturuyor --
-- oturuyorum ama sadece
ama sadece
siyah kalemimi kullanarak
kapkara resimler çiziyorum.
Bu olaydan sonra, dile getirmediğim
duygularımı resme döktüğümü anlıyorum.
Ardından, Rusya'da açtığım
ilk kişisel sergimle
"Rusya'da resim sergisi açan
ilk Türk" unvanını alıyorum.
Henüz 5 yaşındayken kapak resmini
çiziyorum Rus halk masallarının
ve altı yaşındayken de kişisel
sergimi açıyorum orada.
Ardından, Türkiye'ye döndükten sonra
Cumhurbaşkanlığı'nın himayesindeki
"Eğitim Her Engeli Aşar"
kampanyasının simgesi olarak
engellilerin eğitime kazandırılmasında
etkin rol oynuyorum.
İşte tüm bunlar da benim ilkokula
kayıt vaktime denk geliyor
ve işte, ilk engele de
burada takılıyorum aslında
çünkü gideceğim özel okul benim
kaydımı yapmak istemiyordu.
Aylarca yapmadılar
ama bir Türkiye Cumhuriyeti vatandaşı
olarak eğitim hakkım elimden alınamazdı.
Tüm engellere rağmen ilkokula
kaydımı başardık, yaptırdık.
Okulun ilk günü pek de parlak geçmedi,
muhtemelen öğretmenimin fikri alınmamıştı
ve o da beni hiçbir zaman kabullenmedi.
İşte tam da şu an söylemem gerek ki,
idarecilerin özel çocukları
öğretmenlerden kim gönüllüyse ona,
öyle biri yoksa aralarından en
vicdanlısına vermeleri gerekir.
Beni de tam tersine vermişlerdi.
Sanırım o zamana kadar kollarımın
yokluğunu hiç hissetmemiştim
ama o günden sonra benim
için kapkara günler başlamıştı.
Artık içime kapanmıştım,
kendisiyle konuşmak istemiyordum.
Bir keresinde bana,
"Sümeyye, sen işine geldiğinde
benimle konuşuyorsun,
işine gelmediğinde konuşmuyorsun.
Ben de bundan sonra senin tuvaletin
geldiğinde annene haber vermeyeceğim.
Yap bakalım, kendin nasıl
yapabiliyorsan," demişti.
Bu, bana yaşattığı acıların
en basitlerindendi.
Arkadaşlarımdan uzaklaştırma
çabalarını hiç anlatmayacağım bile.
Şimdi, bu sorunlarla nasıl
başa çıktığımı anlatacağım.
Ebru sanatına başladım.
Devlet sanatçısı Didem Üstün'ün
eğitmenliğinde, özel bir atölyede
hem ebrumu yapıyor hem de tüm
bir haftanın stresini atıyordum.
O benim arkadaşım gibiydi.
Bu sayede birçok karma sergiye katıldım
ve ilk kişisel sergimi 11 yaşında açtım.
31 tablodan 27'sinin satıldığı sergimden
kazandığım paralarla gittim,
kendime bir de dikiş makinesi aldım.
Tasarladığım kıyafetleri
kesip biçip dikiyordum.
Yedi yıl boyunca devam
ettiğim ebru sanatına
liseye geçiş sınavları için
bir süreliğine ara verdim.
Bu arada 466 puanla kazandığım lisemde
şu anda dokuzuncu sınıf öğrencisiyim.
Belki de en çok merak ettiğiniz konu,
yüzme serüvenime geçiyorum.
Beş yaşında, Çiğdem hocamın
eğitmenliğinde başladım.
İtiraf etmek gerekirse
başlarda korkuyordum
ama hocamın sevgisi ve sabrıyla
12 saatte yüzmeyi tamamen öğrendim.
Dört yıl sonra, artık tek başıma özel ders
şeklinde olmasından sıkılmaya başlamıştım,
bu yüzden arkadaş istiyordum.
Bir kulübe geçtim.
Orada şu anki antrenörüm
Mehmet Bayrak'la tanıştık
ve Türkiye şampiyonalarına
katılmaya başladım.
Her yarışta altın madalya aldıkça, beni
milli takım kamplarına davet ettiler.
Bu süreç içerisinde ne kadar başarılı
olsam da, arkamdan çok fazla konuşuldu,
"Bu kız yapamaz", "bu kızın
başka hayalleri var",
ondan sonra, "bırakır",
"bırakacaksın", bırakmam."
Bunun gibi birçok şey oldu
ve bunlara inat, pes etmedim.
İlk uluslararası yarışım Berlin'de,
iki gümüş, iki bronz madalyayla
milli sporcu oldum.
Bu süreç içerisinde --
gayet zordu.
Hayallerim hiçbir zaman bitmedi.
Hepsini birlikte de yürütebilirim
ve bu yarışlardan benim için en önemlisi,
ilk ve en küçük sporcu
olarak katıldığım yarıştı.
Meksika Dünya Şampiyonası'nda --
"en küçük ve ilk sporcu olarak
katıldığım" demiştim zaten.
(Alkış)
0,23 saliseyle kürsüyü kaçırdım.
Bu benim için çok büyük bir tecrübeydi.
O an ne kadar üzülüp ağlasam da,
zaten benim geçen rakiplerim 45
yaşlarında olimpiyat şampiyonlarıydı.
Daha sonrasında pozitif yönlerini düşünüp
önümde daha çok uzun yıllar
olduğundan daha çok çalıştım.
Sonuç olarak onlardan daha
diri ve genç bir vücuda sahiptim.
Hatta bu büyük şampiyonalara hazırlık
sürecinde uzun süren kamplarımız oluyor.
Bu kamplarda daha kahvaltı
açılmadan, bilgisayarın --
yani daha doğrusu havuzun bilgisayar
saati bile devreye girmeden
biz buz gibi bir suya giriyoruz.
Şu anda düşününce bile
tüylerim diken diken oldu,
canım acıdı, üşümeye başladım
ama tüm rakiplerini geçerek
İstiklal Marşı okutup bayrağımızı
göklere çıkardığım zaman
her şey unutuluyor.
Tüm acılar unutuluyor.
Neler unutulmadı ki.
Neler unutulmadı, biliyor musunuz?
Üç buçuk yaşımda, kollarımın
olmadığını ilk fark ettiğimde
o kadar özgüveni yüksek,
hayata bağlı bir çocukmuşum ki,
bunu anneme şarkı eşliğinde
Kollar nerede? Kollar, kollar?
diye sorduğumu,
annemin ise bana bir masal kitabındaki
uzvu eksik hayvanların
hikâyelerini okuduğunu,
bana da "Bir Sümeyye varmış, kolu yokmuş
ama her işi ayaklarıyla
yapabiliyormuş," diye anlattığını,
benimse kabul etmeyip "Hayır, benim
büyüyünce kollarım çıkacak," dediğimi,
onunsa "Hayır, senin hiçbir
zaman kolların çıkmayacak.
Sen her şeyi ayaklarınla yapacaksın.
Çarşıya, pazara, alışverişine gideceksin.
Hatta pazarcılar sana hayran olacak,
'Sümeyye, sen bunları kendin
nasıl yapabiliyorsun?' diyecekler,"
dediğini unutmuyorum
ve işte ben o gün kendimi
böyle kabullendim.
Bugünse masal gerçek oldu.
Çantamı alıp tek başıma alışverişime,
çarşıya, pazara çıkıyorum.
Kozmetik alışverişimi kendim yapıyorum.
Bu arada makyaj yapmayı da çok seviyorum,
gördüğünüz makyajı da kendim yaptım.
(Alkış)
Ve farklılıklarımız bizi özel kılar.
Kendini fark et, hayal et
ve farkını yarat.
Benim yaratmak istediğim
farksa, limitlerimi zorlayarak
hem 2020 Tokyo'da, yüzmede Türkiye'nin
ilk olimpiyat şampiyonu olmak
ve akademik anlamda en
üst seviyelere gelmek.
Kendim birçok zorluk yaşadığımdan,
birçok acılar çektiğimden ötürü
engelli, öğrenci, sporcu, sanatçı
psikolojisinden anladığım,
hatta bir gün çocuğum olduğunda
anne psikolojisinden anlayacağım için
psikolog olmak istiyorum.
Şu anda bile bir sosyal medya hesabım var
ve orada başarılarımı,
yazılarımı paylaştıkça
"ilham perisi", "su perisi",
"senin sayende hayata bağlandım",
"seni çok sevdiğim için ben de yüzmeye
başladım" gibi birçok geri dönüş alıyorum
ve bunlar beni çok mutlu ediyor.
Özellikle de en büyük hayallerimden biri
yurt dışında International Paralympic
Committee'de sporcu psikologu olarak
ülkemi temsil etmek
ve haklarımızı savunmak
en büyük hayallerimden biri.
Hayallerim hiçbir zaman bitmedi,
bitmiyor, bitmeyecek de.
Mesela kol kola girmek, el ele tutuşmak,
içine alacakmışçasına sımsıkı sarılmak.
Belki de hayatımda bir mucize olmadığı
sürece yapmam imkansız şeyler
ama omuzlarıma değil de
bacaklarıma baktığımda
yapabileceğim daha birçok şey var
ve içten bakıldığında da, hepiniz gibi
küt küt atan bir kalbim var
ve ben kollarımla değil,
yüreğimle sarılıyorum.
Sizden ricam, ne zaman zifiri
karanlığa düşmüş birini görseniz
ona güneşin asıl şimdi doğmak
üzere olduğundan bahsetmeniz
ve kollarınızla da benim
yerime sımsıkı sarılmanız.
(Alkış)
Beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim.